good afternoon
today the supreme court heard arguments
in a case
that could strike down the affordable
care act in its entirety
if the supreme court agrees with the
opponents of the act
their decision could take health care
away
from 20 million americans it could take
away protections from more than 100
million people
with pre-existing conditions in our
country and hurt the millions of
americans
who have come to rely on the affordable
care act
getting rid of the affordable care act
will take us backward
to a time when people could charge a
woman more for her health care
than they could charge a man simply
because she's a woman
to a time when pregnancy could be
considered a pre-existing condition
it will take away free birth control and
contraceptive coverage for women
this is all happening at a moment when
our country is suffering through a
pandemic
that has claimed more than 238
000 lives and we all know
that if the affordable care act is
struck down
communities of color would be hit
particularly
hard black asian hispanic and native
american
because they are at a greater risk of
pre-existing conditions from
asthma to diabetes to lupus
and they are also three times as likely
to contract covet 19
and twice as likely to die as others
now i know we all know that we just had
an election
in america an election where health care
was very much on the ballot our country
had a clear choice in this election
each and every vote for joe biden was a
statement
that health care in america should be a
right
and not a privilege each and every vote
for joe biden was a vote to protect
and expand the affordable care act
not to tear it away in the midst of a
global pandemic
and joe biden won the election
decisively
with more votes than have ever been cast
in american history
it amounts to 75 million
voices and counting calling on the
supreme court
to see this case for what it is
a blatant attempt to overturn
the will of the people and the
president-elect
and i cannot let that happen
and now it is my honor to introduce
president-elect joe biden
thank you good afternoon everyone
this morning as was stated the united
states supreme court heard oral
on the case of grave importance to the
american people
this case represents the latest attempt
by the far-right ideologues to do what
they've been repeatedly failed to do
for a long time in the courts in the
congress and the court of public opinion
over the last decade to eliminate the
entirety of the affordable care act
twice already the supreme court has
upheld the landmark law
in 2012 and again in 2015
and the congress expressing the popular
will of the american people on a
bipartisan basis
has rejected numerous attempts numerous
efforts by president trump
to erase the law as well now in the
middle of a deadly pandemic
that has infected more than 10 million
americans
nearly one in every 32 americans
often with devastating consequences to
their health
these ideologues are once again trying
to strip
health coverage away from the american
people the goal
of the outgoing administration is clear
from the brief they filed in the supreme
court
it asserts and i quote the entire aca
thus must fall end of quote
now i'm not naive about the fact that
health care is an issue that has divided
americans in the past
but the truth is the american people are
more united on this issue today than
they are divided
recently as last month the leading
survey found that american people want
to keep the affordable care act in place
by an overwhelming margin of 58 to 36
79 percent of the american people
including nine out of ten democrats
eight out of ten independents and
two-thirds of republicans
want to keep the aca protections for
people with pre-existing conditions
which would be eliminated if this
lawsuit were to succeed
this doesn't need to be a partisan issue
it's a human issue it affects every
single american family
we can't subvert the growing consensus
the american people
based on an argument put forward in the
briefs seeking to invalidate the law
that even many conservative legal
scholars including in the national
review consider to be quote
ridiculous let's be absolutely clear
about what's at stake
the consequence of the trump
administration's argument are not
academic or an abstraction for many
americans they are a matter of
life and death in a literal sense this
argument will determine whether health
care coverage
of more than 20 million americans who
acquired under the affordable care act
will be ripped away
in the middle of the nation's worst
pandemic in a century
over 100 million people as the vice
president-elect
pointed out over 100 million people with
pre-existing conditions
like asthma diabetes cancer could once
again be denied coverage
whether complications from covert 19
like
lung scarring and heart damage will be
the next flood of pre-existing
conditions
that could be used as an excuse to jack
up premiums
or deny coverage altogether for millions
of survivors
who have struggled won and fought
the co the coronavirus fought against
the loss of their life
this argument is going to determine
whether women as is pointed out
will once again be charged higher
premiums just because they're women
or seniors will see their prescription
drug costs
go up and like kids who
whether or not they can stay in their
parents plans to age 26
where their annual lifetime benefits
will be
reimposed so someone could walk in and
say
die in peace you run out of your
coverage
it's in hyperbole it's real as real as
it gets
when the family is faced with the awful
news of a child's diagnosis leukemia
or a mom forced to battle against breast
cancer
an accident that leaves loved ones
unable to live the life
they've always known it stops your heart
it stops your heart and wrenches
your entire world right off its axis
when that happens
and many of you know that from your own
personal experiences
believe me i know the feeling and too
many american families do as well
in that moment the very last thing on
your mind
the very last thing should be on your
mind is whether you can afford the
treatment
afford the affordable care act was
created to put a stop
to that in humanity it was created to
ensure that families
thrust into their worst nightmare of
their lives could focus
not only not on money but on the fight
that really matters
obamacare is a law that every american
should be proud of
it's why people with pre-existing
conditions are protected in this country
it's a law that delivered vital coverage
as i said before for 20 million
americans
who did not have coverage it's a law
that reduced prescription drug price
cost
for nearly 12 million seniors
it's a law that saved lives and spared
countless families from financial ruin
so this effort to bypass
the will of the american people the
verdict of the courts in the past the
judgments of congress
in my view is simply cruel and
needlessly divisive
regardless of the outcome of this case i
promise you this
beginning on january 20th the vice
president-elect harris and i
we're going to do everything in our
power to ease the burden of health care
on you
and your families i promise you that as
i said i will protect your health care
like i protect
like as of my own family and we've been
unfortunately
significant consumers of health care
that starts by building on the
affordable care act
with the dramatic expansion of health
care coverage
and bold steps to lower healthcare costs
my transition team will soon be starting
its work
to flesh out the details so that we can
hit the ground running
tackling costs increasing access
lowering the price of prescription drugs
families are reeling right now
particularly the reporters in this room
and others listening you've interviewed
a lot of these people around the country
as you've gone all over the world all
over the country
enduring illnesses faced with risky
choices losing their
employer plans in droves already 10
million have already lost their employer
plans
they need a lifeline and they need it
now
they should have to hold their breath
they shouldn't be in that position
waiting to see if the supreme court is
going to
wrench away the peace of mind
they've come to now rely on
so we're going to get right to work i
promise you
addressing the issues that families are
are talking about around the kitchen
tables this morning
making sure that they can get bed
tonight with the peace of mind that they
deserve
and fulfilling our moral obligation to
ensure that
here in america health care is a right
for all
not a privilege for a few so come
january
we're going to work quickly with the
congress to dramatically ramp up health
care protections
get americans universal coverage lower
health care costs
as soon as humanly possible
that's the promise i make to you we're
going to fight
for your family's health coverage the
same way we fight for our own family's
health coverage
we want every single american to know if
you're sick
if you're struggling if you're worried
about how you're going to
get going to get through the day we will
not abandon you that is a promise
will not leave you to face these
challenges alone
we're going to get through this we're
going to get through it together
and we're going to build a healthcare
system that puts you and your families
first
and that every american can be proud of
i want to thank you all for listening
may god bless you may god keep you safe
in this coveted environment
and may god protect our troops now i'm
told that we're going to have
you're going to we're going to take five
questions there about
okay
thank you mr president-elect during the
campaign
you said you were not naive about how
difficult it would be to
unite the country it's now three days
after
you were projected as the
president-elect the
president himself says he has won this
election his own administration has not
moved forward to give you access to what
you need to do to begin
the work of your transition just a few
minutes ago
the secretary of state when asked if he
would cooperate
with a smooth transition he said there
will be a smooth transition to a second
trump administration i wonder if you
have a message for the president who may
well be watching right now
and how do you expect to be able to work
with republicans when so many
have thus far refused to even
acknowledge your victory well first of
all
uh we are already beginning
the transition we're well underway and
uh
the ability uh for uh
the administration in any way by failure
to recognize us as
our win uh does not uh
change the dynamic at all what we're
able to do
we've announced yesterday as you know
the health
group that we put together today we're
going to be going moving along
in a in a consistent manner
putting together our administration the
white house and
reviewing who we're going to pick for
the cabinet physicians
and nothing's going to stop that and uh
and so i'm confident that the fact that
they're not willing to acknowledge we
want at this point
is not of much consequence in our
planning and what we're able to do
between now
and january 20th give response to
secretary pompeo and i also
i also wonder you warned during the
campaign that as the walls closed in on
the president he would behave more
erratically yesterday he fired his
defense secretary
on twitter are you worried that he's
disabling the government and
what are you saying to the world leaders
who are calling you at this point about
the situation here first of all uh
i'm letting him know that america is
back uh we're going to be back in the
game
it's not american alone number one i've
got had the opportunity to speak
with now six world leaders
and uh and the response has been
very fulsome energetic
and uh they're all looking forward to
being able to
from from great britain to france to
germany to canada et cetera
and ireland so i feel good about the
ability to
i said when we announced that the next
president is going to
inherit a divided country and a world in
disarray
the reception and welcome we've gotten
around the world from our allies and our
friends has been real
i'm having a number of other calls to
return and
so i feel confident that we're going to
be able to
put the ameri put america back in
the place of respect that it had before
mr president-elect senate majority
leader mitch mcconnell has suggested
today that he may not recognize
the outcome of this election until the
electoral college meets
next month have you spoken to your long
time friend in the senate mr mcconnell
and what do you make of his specific
comments
over the last 24 hours i haven't had a
chance to speak to mitch
my expectation is that i will do that
not too distant future um i think that
the whole republican party has been put
in a position with
a few notable exceptions of
being mildly intimidated by the
sitting present but there's only one
president at a time
he's president we're going to have the
electoral college we'll
be making their judgment in december
it'll be announced in early january
but in the meantime i hope to get a
chance to speak to mitch if i could
follow up without transition funding
will you be able to
go through with the proper transition
that's needed
would you like access to the pdb and
will you
authorize legal action or would that be
too divisive do you believe
i we can get through without
uh the the funding uh we're in a
position that
uh we feel very good about our there's
nothing that slows up our efforts to put
things together
obviously the pdb would be useful but
it's not necessary i'm not the sitting
president now
and so we don't see anything in slowing
us down quite frankly
thank you
thank you mr president-elect and
congratulations to you both
have you tried to reach out at all to
the president and if he is watching
right now
what would you say to him mr president
look forward to speaking with you
and you say that you are being able to
move ahead without interruption but
to jeff's point presumably at some point
you will need access to more classified
information
to secure facilities and the like what
options
are you considering how will you uh move
ahead if the president continues to
refuse to concede
well look uh access
to classified information is uh
is useful uh but i'm not a position to
make any decisions
on those issues anyway there's one as i
said one president at a time
and he will be president until january
20th
it would be nice to have it but it's not
critical and
that's we're just going to proceed the
way we have we're going to
we're going to do exactly what we'll be
doing if he had conceded and said
we've won which we have uh and so
there's nothing really changing
but not ruling out legal action no i
don't see a need for
a big election uh quite frankly i think
the legal action
is uh you're seeing it play out
the actions he's taking and so far
there is no evidence of any of the
assertions made
by the president or secretary state
pompeo
secretary of state pompeo
thank you mr president-elect democrats
are on track to lose a handful of seats
in the house of representatives
that could make it harder to pass
legislation with just democratic votes
i'm just curious how does that impact
your plans
for what priorities you think you can
get through this congress
especially if the senate remains in gop
control
and during the lame duck will you be
coordinating with speaker pelosi on how
she should be negotiating with
republicans
well i've spoken to the leader and i've
spoken to the
minority leader in the house and uh one
of the urgent things that need be done
is people need relief right now
right now small businesses people who
are about to be evicted from their homes
because they can't pay their mortgage
unemployment insurance you know what's
going to happen is you're going to see
what people don't realize is the failure
to provide
state local assistance you're going to
see police officers
firefighters first responders laid off
and i think the pressure is
is going to build but the fact is that
i would hope that the president at least
has the
the sensitivity and knowledge you know a
lot of people
are in real trouble right now between
now and the time we get elected
till we get sworn in and so it's my hope
and expectation
i'm sure that the majority
the speaker of the house as well as the
minority leader
are working right now into the
priorities they have laid out
but do you plan to be active in those
negotiations working with speaker pelosi
to
represent democrats in the table well i
they we've been talking and they know my
views and
and i support what they're doing and
then my second question was about the
senate
do you plan to campaign in georgia
before your inauguration to help
democrats in the two run off races there
as they try to flip the senate
and how important is a democratic held
senate to your agenda
well obviously it'd be much better if we
had uh
a tie in the senate which means that
this vice president become incredibly
important beyond what she already is
but we're we're gonna do anything we can
that they think we can do to help
and does the democratic senate help your
cabinet chances that does that
uh change how you consider who you
nominate to cabinet posts
no i don't think so i i i take uh
mcconnell at his word i understand he
said that he will make it clear who he's
prepared to support not support and
that's a negotiation
that i'm sure will have look one of the
things that
that i would do as uh as president
elect and when i become president is lay
out
to the republicans as well as the
democrats who we intend to
name for each cabinet position i hope
we're able to be in a position to let
people know
at least a couple that we want before
thanksgiving and we'll just work this
out
look i am i am not
a pessimist as you know and i think
there are
enough republicans who have already
spoken out but i think
there will be many more not many more
there'll be
a larger number once the uh
the election is declared and i'm sworn
in
to be able to get things done i think
they understand for example i
can't imagine there not being a
willingness on the part of
republicans they're going to be
significant pressure to deal with health
care
their own constituencies are in that
position so
i i'm not i i think we can get a lot
done
sir what do you say to the americans
that are anxious over the fact that
president trump has yet to concede and
what that might mean for the country
well um i just think it's an
embarrassment
quite frankly the only thing that
how can i say this tactfully i think it
will not help the president's legacy
i think that i know from my discussions
with foreign leaders thus far that
they are hopeful that the united states
democratic institutions are viewed once
again as being strong and endured
and but i think at the end of the day uh
you know it's all going to come to
fruition on january 20th
and between now and then i hope an
expectation is
that the american people are do know and
do understand that there has been a
transition even among
republicans who are people who voted for
the president
i understand the sense of loss i get
that
but i think the majority of the
people who voted for the president a lot
voted for him a significantly smaller
number but a lot voted for him
i think they understand that we have to
come together i think they're ready to
unite and i believe we can pull the
country
out of this
bitter politics that we've seen for the
last
last five six seven years and just to
follow up on a previous question
how do you expect to work with
republicans if they won't even
acknowledge you as president-elect
they will they will
thank you all so very much thank you